[Musique]
j'aimerais que comme dans le grand frère
vous disiez quelque chose voilà vous
fassiez un reproche à une personne de
ton de la table voilà un truc que vous
avez à lui reprocher en tapant bien sûr
son état de grâce
alors faites attention vite à retourner
vous parce que je veux pas que le faux
nom il le fasse benjamin castaldi et moi
j'avais un truc à raccrocher acquis
benjamin castel à maxime gainey c'est
quoi allez-vous maxime talbot ce cadre
soit autant je mets mon casque a été
vraiment galère on va très bien mais ça
ça va faire un bien on est complètement
ouf
j'aurais travaillé dur à mener ma ville
tranquille thomas calvot ouidah arrête
de te dénigrer arrête de donner une
vraie voilà comme ça c'est dit ac
jean-michel pour kevin ouais kelly tu as
osé traîner dans la boue et l'amour que
je t'avais déclaré au public nous ça
pourra prête à jeter dans les bras cette
petite en furent de maxime gherib lirez
jamais qu'à l'opéra
[Applaudissements]
jean michel gaudin trucks et passe en
coulisses lundi soir alors est ce que
pour lui raconter dans un instant
mojorité cancan coeur parce que j'ai la
patience
il s'est passé un truc lundi soir avec
jean michel et kelly vous avez pas du
tout entre maxime et qu'il y a pas très
bien vous avez deux femmes à tsinga ni
mathieu tu te prends pour qui
de rêver
[Applaudissements]
oui oui la paire la personne est
curieuse jolie voix terriblement à
kostroma malaisie attention sur la
rocade
benjamin tu disais que tu es mon ami je
sais que les crimes de haine alors tu es
petit tu es fait bonbons à la montre
d'abord que pour s'assurer que thomas
michaud épicerie jose mar vraiment en
dehors bien sûr vous piquent des moments
à la vente ce qui la dépouillent les
daleks comme ça à chaque coupure depuis
six mois je suis son épicerie ouais
alors je crois que l'état me mets pas du
tout si vous avez des suppôts aussi
donnez lui il a des problèmes pour finir
sur la flèche vous raconte pas alors
juste après des sages attendraient que
je monte ici vous allez être déçus
[Rires]
corinne s'il te plaît tu quand tu parles
tu hurles tu gesticule et quand je suis
à côté de toi j'ai l'impression que je
vais me prend une droite alors pourrait
[Applaudissements]
gilles verdez calme mais tes lunettes
isabelle métayer tchador on va se
retrouver dans the last show ce mythe
s'il vous plaît pas sur nous et notre
regard est ce vous avez un reproche à
faire à quelqu'un mais vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sortez santé n'est pas supportable
sortez supportable sortant n'a pas y
aller mais qu'on lit des mécanismes
naturels intestines et bien non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
son exécution est croqué parce que le
mec était tard et à leurs proches et
jamais regarder si par environ mais ça
vient jamais un psychiatre qui regardent
l'émission qui fait leur boulot sous la
gare n'était pas dans le froid sans nom
pour l'internaute à dent malade
la mise à sac de la borne s'est passé à
la maman alors maman calme vous
tranquille mais non mais justement
qu'avez-vous d'un week end ou non pas à
côté là bas mais j'ai continué parce que
ça la tâche de mardi va faire doucement
à faire du sport c'est bien tout est
allé j'aime bien de martory justement si
tu m'entends l'impassible pour toi non
seulement tu éteins braid est une ville
complètement fou et a failli me blesser
bon bah c'est bon c'est bon mais lens
étant même avant les personnages
merci
[Applaudissements]
non non non pas pour l'instant pas pour
la sécurité on vient menacer la sécurité
du blanc moi c'est rien c'est tout petit
tout petit critique à géraldine maillet
à ces rien tant qu'on est tranquille tu
vois géraldine mention carradine mon
coeur tu m'emmerdes écriture merde
acadie keim et documentaires alors que
j'habite à jamais été foutu d'en sortir
un à toulouse en direct au monopole du
bon goût tu les ennuis avec tes bouquins
alors qu'ils étaient pas la pléiade
tu nous ennuie a critiqué la télé
réalité tu te fais chier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur